[Music]
this week 18 months after shutting down
for the pandemic several broadway shows
reopened that's right
broadway is back
and i
am so excited now so many of my favorite
shows have returned the lion king wicked
chicago hamilton and to celebrate come
on guys you know i gotta do a little
song and dance
it
[Music]
the name on
everybody's lips is gonna be
due to copyright laws the sound from
this broadcast has been prohibited we at
peacock do not own the rights to any of
these very famous broadway songs nor do
we want to pay for them
as a matter of fact we told amber not to
do this sketch
we at peacock said amber not only will
it be impossible to get the rights but
you will be very very tired by the end
of this
she said phooey and then kissed we at
peacock on the lips and skipped out of
the room like that wasn't an hr
violation
she thinks the people at home can hear
her right now but there's no way we
would let that happen
andrew lloyd webber is very litigious
look at her go she's so happy
[Applause]
oh look we've moved on to the hamilton
portion of whatever this is
it looks like she's rapping very well
it's a shame we'll never know
did you know tarik is friends with
lin-manuel miranda he might have been
his best man
we at peacock ask you not to quote us on
that
what's everybody eating for dinner
tonight
we at peacock are thinking of ordering
thai
does pat thai have gluten in it
anyway we haven't decided yet
oh wait she's almost done
now back to your regularly scheduled
program
[Music]
we'll be right back with more of the
emma ruffin show did you like my singing
okay stick around
because if you think that was good why
don't you see what's coming after the
break
[Music]
you